as the star of one of the most
long-lived superhero film franchises
Hugh Jackman is being contractually
obligated to keep his body in a near
constant state of shredded nurse since
1999
that's just how it goes when you're
famous for playing a character whose
costume often consists of one pair of
adamantium claws and a veiny pair of
pecs
but how did Jackman transform from a
six-foot to 180 pound bean pole into the
muscle-bound Wolverine he is everything
that goes into making and maintaining
his incredible physique he never skips
the gym if you've been watching Jackman
play Wolverine since the very beginning
you might have noticed that he hasn't
just kept himself in shape
he's clearly set out to make each of his
appearances even more physically
intimidating than the last
when Jackman first showed up in 2000
x-men he looked good but in an
achievable way like your friend from
work who goes to the gym in the morning
and only drinks lite beer
celebrity trainer David Kingsbury
revealed Jackman's formula for success
and it involves going to the gym six
days a week twice a day the actor
follows a four week workout cycle when
he's planning to slip back into his
adamantium laced bones the first three
weeks are all about lifting heavy and
pushing huge amounts of weight for only
a few repetitions the fourth week
Jackman D loads and the lifts smaller
amounts but at a higher volume which
stimulates muscle growth so that he will
be as big as possible on-screen the
whole thing is pretty much murder on his
wardrobe his boxes in my storage fat
suits skinny suits normal suits and and
right now in this shape I don't have any
suits Jackman told the LA Times that
there's one thing that he favors above
all when it comes to transforming his
body for a new x-men movie the deadlift
and that's not just a clever pun he eats
all the food when it comes to building a
screen ready physique your workouts are
less than half the battle are you gonna
try any gonna train hard but if you
don't eat right now
to get Wolverine style muscles Jackman
has to seriously shovel it in Jackman
told Men's Fitness I eat more but I eat
a lot stricter 70 percent of your
physique is your diets and diets is the
biggest change that happens there were
times when I would literally eat with
the mindset of working out one more
mouthful one more come on come on you've
gotta finish this meal the actor's Xmen
diet of 6,000 calories per day was
recommended by a guy who knows a thing
or two about getting buff for a role
I literally rang Dwayne Johnson the rock
ok man I've seen you in some movie I
said what's going on what if what do I
do and before you go thinking that this
doesn't sound so terrible keep in mind
that Jackman superhero diet is high in
calories but low in carbs which means
that he has to get those six styles on
the calories primarily in the form of
grilled chicken breast spinach and the
occasional scoop of brown rice though
Jackman was seen celebrating with some
very own diet like foods after Logan
finished filming he uses what nature
gave him before he spends the rest of
your life leaping into a bowl of
buttered popcorn over the unattainable
awesomeness of Hugh Jackman's abs no
that's getting a body like his isn't
just a question of chicken breasts bicep
curls and impeccable genes Jackman's
trainer explained that the actus diet
and training regimen included the use of
creatine a supplement that stimulates
muscle growth beyond what the body can
accomplish on its own he explained we
used a pre-workout product called animal
pump while bulking we use creatine in
the products and when cutting we reduced
and then removed the creatine it's not
exactly the Weapon X program even the
strictest anti-doping regulators are
cool with the use of creatine and it's
been a regular item on the menu for
bodybuilders and athletes since the
1990s but it is one of the reasons why
you don't look like Wolverine at despite
your best efforts Broadway bud Jackman
is a stage actor first and foremost with
a background on Broadway it'd be the
first to tell you that Wolverine for all
his exceptional talents would not be
much of a dancer so the actor doesn't
hang on to a super heroic physique when
he's doing shows in between superhero
flicks he told the LA Times when I dance
I drop a muscle very quickly the body is
very smart and efficient and they
traditional dancers body is not going to
be built up on top because they
you don't really need while doing stage
work make us jackman his biceps it also
has the benefit of keeping jackman in
terrific shape when the cameras stop
rolling the actor still stays busy and
active and it doesn't let himself go so
when it comes time to bulk up a zurka
style
he's starting from a very good place he
stays accountable getting in superhero
shape isn't just diet and exercise it's
also a question of mindset and
motivation so where does Jackman get the
mental fortitude to enjoy the months of
torture that precede a new x-men flick
he gets it from you of course Jackman
always makes sure his followers know
when he's back in the gym and that's not
just because he enjoys watching his
Instagram likes rollin when you've told
your fans to expect photos and video of
you doing clap push-ups or dead lifting
the weight of a fat Shetland pony you've
got to bring it at the gym or risk
disappointing them so when you follow
Jackman on Instagram and dutifully press
that little heart icon for his clips
from the gym you're doing your part to
make sure he shows up in Logan looking
like a muscular nest of pythons with a
human head thanks for watching click the
loop icon to subscribe to our youtube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know your love to